okay we're ready now
okay can i welcome everybody to
tonight's licensing subcommittee for the
10th of march uh attendances will be
noted
uh we're just here to
hear one item which is the objection for
environmental help to a temporary event
notice issued by it sorry issued for gbe
limited
ashburton house trafford park road
uh trafford park
so
we do some introductions i'm councillor
german i'm chairing the panel and with
me i've got councillors taylor and
holden um we have offices for the
licensing legal and governance team with
us tonight
uh now we have the applicant mr oliver
you've already
already up and introduced yourself thank
you
um
and do we have uh
um nicola from environmental health
please she's in the
yeah
yeah i'm here
and okay thank you and katie armstrong
from licensing's observing
okay so
what i'll do is i'll run through the
procedure for the meeting um
and then
i'll ask if there's any questions about
the procedure and then and then we'll
we'll get straight into it
so
the first step is i'll ask the licensing
officer to outline the application
i will then ask the applicant to address
the subcommittee and call any witnesses
the applicant and each of the witnesses
may then be questioned by members of the
subcommittee officers and any other
party making representation
the party making representation
who will be referred to as the
representative and or the
representatives will be given an
opportunity to address the subcommittee
and call any witnesses
the represent the representative may
then be questioned by members of the
subcommittee
officers and any other party making
representations
um so we've only got one rep
representative which is the
environmental health representation
after this i will request all parties
involved to summarize the representative
uh will be given two minutes to
summarize
followed by the applicant will also be
given two minutes to summarise
some the subcommittee will then consider
their decision and then i will announce
the determination of the application
and the reasons for the determination
this will be confirmed in writing within
five days of the hearing
so is everybody clear about the
procedure
yeah okay
in that case i'll ask
ms boyle if she'd uh like to outline the
application please
thank you chair members of the
subcommittee as a report states part
five of the licensing act 2003 provides
a system of permitted temporary
activities under which licensable
activities can be carried out on a
temporary basis without the need for a
premises license or a club premises
certificate
no no permission is required from the
licensing authority and only the police
environmental health may intervene with
a view to preventing such an event going
ahead or to modify the arrangements for
it
if the police or environmental health
object to attend the licensing authority
must hold a hearing to determine whether
or not it accepts the objections
where the authority accepts the
objections it must issue a counter
notice to the premises user in which
case the event cannot proceed as
proposed
on the 28th of february 2022 uh the
premises user mr samuel oliver served a
temporary event notice on the authority
for premises known as gve limited
ashburton house stratford park road in
trafford park a copy of that notice is
attached at appendix a
these premises currently benefit from a
premises license which cover the outdoor
decking area
this area has permission for sale of
alcohol on and off the premises from of
700 hours to 2 300 hours and late night
refreshment from 2 300 hours to 23 30
hours
and is known as the six trees bar
the turn has been issued to extend the
current licensable activities from the
decking area into the adjacent first
floor office space to facilitate a 48
hour electronic music show with live and
recorded music late night refreshment
and the sale of alcohol
the hours proposed are
on the 1st of april 2022 from 22 on 2100
hours sorry to over 600 hours and on the
2nd of april 2022 from 2 100 hours to
over 600 hours
on the 3rd of march
2022 an objection to the notice was
received from the environmental health
team
on the grounds of public safety as the
end of the proposed event will coincide
with the start of the manchester
marathon
it is the opinion of the environmental
health officer that the egress plan
submitted by the premises user has not
taken into consideration the impact of
the marathon and the surrounding road
closures and the ability of people at
the premises to egress the event safely
a copy of the objection is attached
appendix c
the ten can be modified at any time
before a hearing is held with the
agreement of the premises user and the
relevant authority which has objected
this could be by way of changing the
parts of the premise that are to be used
for the event the nature of the intended
activities or their duration
in the sub submission from environmental
health it is stated that a number of
suggestions have been made to the
premises user to mitigate their concerns
but this matter is before the
subcommittee because agreement could not
be reached and the objection has not
been withdrawn
there is a premises license in place on
part of the premises which are the
subject of this ten therefore the
subcommittee can impose conditions on
the ten to the extent that they are on
the existing premises licence
or the subcommittee can decide that is
necessary for the promotion of the
licensing objectives to accept the
objection
and to issue the process user a counter
notice under section 105 of the
licensing act 2003 which would mean that
the licenseable activities were not
authorized
and chair that concludes my summary of
the matter before the subcommittee today
thank you
thank you miss doyle um so just to be
clear are we considering all
matters relating to the license
area for the 10 or are we just
considering the fact that um it clashes
with the
manchester marathon on the sunday with
the road closures
you'll consist you're considering the
full tent application in front of you
so that is um
the extension of hours the extension of
area
um that is proposed so the plans have
been submitted
and the extension of hours
right on the objection obviously
obviously the objection from heroin to
health
thank you very much does anybody else
have any questions for the licensing
officer
no okay in that case uh can i ask uh the
applicant mr oliver if you'd like to
speak to his uh application in support
of his application please
you're on you're on mute
hello oh you got me now
got you now yeah thank you so yes so
this this is the first hearing i've had
to attend we've had a number of um event
notices go through uh when i've spoke to
nicola back and forth um we were in
agreement that there was there was no
issue with the the first part of the
event taking place on the first it was
directly linked to the hours after 3 a.m
in the morning on sunday the 3rd to do
with the marathon
and we were told the objection was put
in based on the fact that we couldn't
come to an agreement before
the
72-hour notice period
now there is a number of suggestions
been put in and we we were again coming
back from the same point that if we do
reach the point of objecting
on the
the second part on the second to the
third we would like to continue and
resubmit the notice for the first
uh but i have spoken to
the other organizers and with the
promoters
and
we did first look at moving the date
this seems to be the only viable date
it's a show that me and my partner have
put together with a couple of groups in
a new space that we've been working
towards so
everyone is very much determined if
possible for us to set up a plan around
it to make it a viable and safe egress
um some of the stuff i've noticed that
was put into nicola's report are the
same stuff that we've discussed about
having the extra cost to us to provide
shuttle bus and coach service to allow
people to be removed from the area
safely i think i'd i'd put a an initial
response back to nicola saying having
you know three or four coaches laid on
because we did a similar thing in
wolverhampton where the the venue was
quite far away from transport links
um and then i had no issue nicola had
also countered when i had read her
description later that he would want
some sort of service on from three
o'clock when the road closes to begin
uh
i haven't got anything
finished in writing but i've spoke to
the security company they're here this
weekend who are happy to assist us until
the end of egress whether that goes an
hour an hour over um i've spoke to the
promoters they're happy to share the
cost of putting on additional transport
we have a local taxi firm based in
trafford park who are happy to assist us
with additional taxi services and then
we've discussed and we're waiting for
quotes back at the moment for that night
to have uh 17 see a shuttle bus on hand
from three o'clock when the road
closures start and then i was gonna
ask for again a little bit more
information on what level would be
acceptable of having between two and
four coaches put on at five o'clock to
egress people out of traffic park and to
the other side of the blockades
i know the issue at the moment is the
only loop round would be uh onto the
ring road around the motorway which
probably rightly said it might be
difficult for taxis to do but if we had
a dedicated bus service to do this
we think we could manage it we have
looked to all of our angles of
postponing
or delaying or changing the times but it
doesn't fit with the event and the issue
we've got is we put quite a lot of work
into bringing two teams of promoters
together to do this and we worry if we
lose it to a different venue
the first one that we did that we put a
lot of work into
you know we may lose on out on that in
the future so we are kind of dedicated
to doing everything we can to satisfy
environmental health but allow the event
to proceed
okay thank you mr oliver so i take it
you're unaware that the marathon was on
when you yeah i i think
again nikola explained to us that the
council is supposed uh we should have
had notice but possibly because our
normal operating hours are only till 11
we may not have been
taken into account as a business that
may affect i know when we've had the
normal marathon it's completely
decimated our service the next day and
we didn't get notice but we did only
open
on the first of may last year so we may
just not not be on the radars at the
moment you know for this sort of thing
we kind of missed out this was put in
i think tickets have been sold as a
secret location when when everything
should have gone through we've put quite
a lot of work already into collating it
and then this came through as a bit of a
surprise at the last minute
so again we'd like to damage control and
and if it costs us a little bit more
money to lay on an egress plan at our
own expense
we would be happy to kind of meet your
requirements you know in in putting
those things in place we had everything
in writing and the bookings confirmed
first we'd hope that would be enough to
satisfy your needs
okay well thank you for that uh well
we'll hear from the environmental health
officer later but what what you're
saying is you're committed to the dates
and times as applied but what you're
saying is you're prepared to
to meet on the meters on the shuttle bus
oh absolutely i think i think i'd
replied to nicola on email before i'd
read further down in the response
they've mentioned the shuttle bus and
i'd explained that we attended event in
wolverhampton where it was
like out in the sticks uh like a school
gym and it was 25 minutes from town or
any transport and they laid on a coach
service so people come out pay the pound
ticket to get on and that would take
them back to
you know an appropriate place so we'll
be looking to do something
along those lines i think from from our
figures and what we've put together if
we've got a capacity of 480 and it was
to sell out you we would imagine that
that full crowd would be in there for
kind of a peak two hours from about half
twelve to about half two
and then from about half two you would
get a gradual egress so i can see
nickelodeon put three o'clock having
some sort of shuttle bus we'd happily
put a shuttle bus on from three and then
you would expect probably between the
two and three hundred people to be there
till the end of the show so at that
point we would lay on maybe three or
four full coaches with about 50 capacity
each that could take the full crowd and
bring them to an appropriate place
well okay thank you for that if that's
acceptable we'd have to obviously work
up the detail
and i know the objection went in at the
time because in the three-day limit we
just didn't have time to come to to a
solid written agreement i've now got
written statement from the security and
from the promoter i'm just waiting for
quoted prices confirmed from a number of
different coach carriers to confirm they
can attend i haven't received all that
okay
can i just ask you what sort of
entertainment you you're actually
putting on there it's uh djs and and and
live music why one of the events uh both
both the events are run by good friends
of ours uh the first evening is
a mixture of djs and instrumental a good
friend of ours who plays a number of
festivals and
a number of shows around manchester they
do like a combined electronic
and percussion set where they they play
live drum music uh on drum kits as well
as electronic it's quite a spectacle
and then the second night is another
similar thing is quite a successful two
successful nights in manchester again
something we've discussed before
is the the crowd age um with john at
licensing
from the police and he said it's usually
a lot more difficult with younger crowds
this is a confirmed older crowd one one
one group is 26 and up and the other is
30 and up so we think we are dealing
with an older more sensible crowd
everybody will be electronic music the
one specifically that we're talking
about on the saturday night
is
two different
um
kind of popular nights and we're friends
with both and we've asked them to
combine so it's the first time this has
combined and we think it could be you
know quite a big thing for for the
industry and we're
a little bit afraid to lose it to
somewhere else who will you know we'll
have a really good night out of it and
then try and keep it at their venue
okay thank you i actually went down to
see your place yesterday obviously i
didn't go in but i looked round from the
outside
certainly got a nice impressive outdoor
area um but i did go and see the notice
on the door and you only seem to be
advertising an act for the saturday
night you know a specific act yeah but
the reason we've done that so far is
because of this situation um
because they've been put on hold
they're still classed as a secret
location on their communications online
in case they have to move venue so we
haven't put any any notice up at the
moment that we've got an event on until
we figure this out we thought it would
be
you know a bit irresponsible to do that
and then have a rejection of people you
know bought tickets on that basis
so there's the downstairs the building
is my engineering firm that's been here
30 years and the outside was just kind
of a response to
covid you know in the situation while
we're in lockdown me and me brothers
built the outside space and then the
upstairs space is kind of built from how
cold it was and not being able to
survive you know just with an outdoor
decking
so we're kind of working on this space
with on the temporary event notices kind
of collecting data for 12 months to see
whether an event space is is a viable
option
okay thank you for that i'll ask my
colleagues on the pan with
any of them have any questions
counselor holder
that's better get me mute off
i have
a concern it's a great concern i just
like you to talk to it if you would
um
the logistics
of this
effectively limited time park and ride
that you're suggesting
for getting people
in
and out
on that one night
the second night
so that the road closures which are
going to be cutting you off from the
manchester direction uh don't affect the
the process
where would you be
expecting to take people
from your venue to
connect with some sort of transport
infrastructure in this one as a warning
um after
an event where they're going to be
tired
shall we say
uh when they're
when they're heading home
i'd just like to expand on your
experience of that wolverhampton
area um that
where you're turning as it would
and i'd just like to understand that
because that frightens me
people being
wandering around unsupervised
in the small hours of the morning um
trying to find some sort of transport
out so you just stand
yeah so
again in terms of the getting to the
event like you mentioned at the
beginning um
the road closures come in effect at
three and we would have a last entry at
1 30 as as normal practice so everyone
would be encouraged to get there before
the road closures it shouldn't affect
the beginning of the event
uh in terms of leaving after um again
this was a little bit more detailed in
the email that i sent over to nicola um
and she'd mentioned shuttle bus a
shuttle bus you tend to from the three
o'clock time where the road closures
take effect you tend to get a slow
egress where taxis and anyone who really
can't get across would join a shuttle
bus and be taken back to you know like a
station or a manchester area on the
other side if they're egressing that way
we've spoke to the taxi firm and the
taxi firm have got both a city center
and an ernst truffle park depot so
anybody grassing away from the blockades
will be directed towards taxis anybody
who needs to get to the other side of
the blockage who go around the ring road
and take them into town
or into an area where they can find
transport links whether it's kind of
over to the other side of white city or
you know to a place where they can do it
in the the early hours
again again one of the main concerns as
as we we thought and was what i'd put in
the in the email to nicola was that
obviously 200 people in in droves of 50
if it ended up being like that on on
separate buses that obviously fill them
up as they fill up and send one so
there'll be a little bit of a difference
in between but i had put in it that we
would be open to discussing appropriate
drop-off points so they weren't all
being dropped off into one area i
understand dropping 200 people off at
piccadilly station creates a problem
within itself so we will be more than
happy to say
discuss four appropriate places where we
could drop people near a major transport
link i think
we're quite unlucky that the times where
if we're finishing at six we do have a
metro service starting at seven
so we go which is outside our building
we'd mentioned maybe prolonging the
event until the metro was on
for this reason but that was kind of
pushed back so if we had somewhere again
we said open to discussion because this
will be back and forth with the
environmental health
if there was say four appropriate
different places that are on the other
side of the blockade that that would be
our plan to put in place rather than
dumping 200 tired people in in in one
place whether the transport links are
you know not not able to deal with it i
think evacuation of a coach at a time in
strategic places would would definitely
would definitely be able to manage this
thank you for that and second question
this time for you nicole
given what
we now know about the
process for
exiting on marathon day
what's your opinion of the
feasibility of
that plan
um well obviously we'd need to see some
confirmed detail um there's quite
extensive road closures i don't know
whether you've seen the marathon um plan
um there's quite a lot of manchester and
trafford
salford that are hit with um road
closures from 3am
on the saturday on sunday morning so
it's not going to be easy and i think
the main the main concern um i've
liaised with um tfgm and gmp around this
before i've made the objection because
in a sense you know samuel is correct i
haven't got an objection to the event if
it was on another day that that would be
okay
um
but you know
just i think taxis are gonna struggle
and i don't want people stranded in
trafford park at a time when businesses
are going to be coming out for a morning
shift people are going to be coming in
there's going to be confusion about road
closures
and the tram
although it does start at seven o'clock
it terminates at cornbrook and there's
obviously going to be a lot of people
that are trying to use that service
because they're coming either to watch
the marathon or to join the marathon so
it's going to be a really busy area
um around that time i mean if samuel is
able to
um come up with a plan using shuttle
buses then obviously that would be fine
if you can get the people out of there
it's just we haven't
had any confirmed details which is why
we've continued with the objection and i
was quite happy and suggested to samuel
that he would draw the application and
resubmit it once he confirmed
all the all the details um would be
acceptable but it at the moment in its
current form we don't have anything
confirmed so my you know objection still
stands up at this time
would
a question can i ask a question as well
because i'm not
yeah yeah yeah just because i've not
been this is like the third tens
application i've gone through
um the main thing i don't want to do is
is lose both obviously because we've got
another one on the line if i was to
withdraw it and submit for the first
and then put the plan in place for the
date on the second
am i allowed to do that or am i not
allowed to put in another application
within 24 hours of the first one i don't
want to kind of trip myself up with with
paperwork and end up like stuck in a you
know in a situation there where we do
satisfy it but because i've applied for
the first i then have i'm not allowed to
put in the one for the second does that
make sense
i've read the documents and i think i
might trip myself up there and doing it
that way which is why i wanted to
converse with you first and make sure i
was going down the right route i think
we need to have another
legal officer
or our licensing officer whoever wants
to take that one on
i'll take that on board chair
um
there has to be a 24-hour gap between
110 and another so um
i would have to submit the whole thing
again i would suggest so yeah i would
suggest so yeah
okay
yeah and if i again just just to clarify
because i'm i'm more than happy to do it
that way if i was to put the work in to
try and put this egress plan in
and resubmit it as a whole event with
both days and what we what i think is a
correct plan and we're still not happy
when i put that application in can i
still
take the second day off and and
just apply for the first day if that
makes sense
like re repackage the tens removing the
second date as they all just come so
quickly we just didn't have time to do
it so if i resubmit
with all the coach thing and everything
confirmed of what we suggested and we
think we can do and and you still decide
it's not can i take the second off and
just keep the event for the first yeah
well i would have thought so and i've
started collecting this on wrong but i
didn't see any problem with that so when
a 10 is submitted um it can be modified
through agreements between
um the premises user and
environmental health or other police so
it could be modified to remove
that
second day yeah so because it was the
first process we just didn't have time
in those three days so it's given me a
lot more information
yeah so what what you need to do
obviously is is make an agreement with
the bus company companies
yeah i've got a few out for quotation at
the minute which i'm just waiting to
come back so as soon as i have that i'd
be able to finish the package in the
egress plan yeah
put that all together and resubmit and
if it doesn't just chuck it off
would be more than one trip would it or
would it would you do it all in one the
initial plan was to have
a smaller shuttle bus on um after
reading nicolas email from the three
o'clock time which just kind of went and
came back from about three o'clock for
anyone who was struggling to get taxes
in that direction
and then have a multiple coaches because
when again when going back to
wolverhampton there was about four
coaches would cover 200 people we don't
foresee there being more than
say
between the two and 300 at the end point
so if we could cover 200 people getting
put back into town we were
able to get at least 100 into normal
taxes with the support of the firm
who've all already signed off for us
that they will support us on that day
right you've got an agreement with a
taxi company as well yeah we've got a
taxi company they've supported us on a
couple of events and they they've come
down they've spoke to us they want to
set up an agreement where they're linked
with us so if people are using our venue
they'll get discounts so this is
regardless of just this event they want
to set up a
constant work
relationship with a venue you know where
they know they're going to get confirmed
business on a regular basis uh but
they've already said i told them about
the road closures they said their two
depots are city center and trafford
parker's so their second depot is on our
side of the blockages and they will
happily support us on that night right
so will they give you a dedicated
service between
a and b
x and y time sort of thing and then keep
i can ask them to confirm in that way as
well it would normally be that they will
just have
the depot full of cars that they send
knowing this event on when we've done it
last time the cars are driving up you
know every couple of minutes whereas if
we don't
let anyone know you can be waiting 20
minutes for one one taxi whereas if we
we're on the register they hold taxes in
our area ready for them to flow you know
throughout the duration of the event
yeah because you know at the end they
sent about
about
eight to ten taxis last time turned up
at ten two as well just all blank taxes
without bookings as well as their them
being posted all over so they gave us a
dedicated service and then a surge at
the end
yeah of course because it's meeting the
capacity isn't it so it's yeah exactly
dedicated service where they're coming
back on repeat so yeah i think i think
so far we've had a number of 2 300
capacity events and then we had one on a
temporary event notice on the 29th of
january that was our first complete
sellout
so we had 480 completely sold out
managed it well i have john lloyd from
the gmp police departments came down
playing clothes to watch our egress plan
uh with the security everyone was on
radios
uh he was he was impressed we talked
about improvement
that we would make you know on things
that he did see uh he specifically said
that the lad in the beanie hat whoever
that was that was actually me it was out
there in the morning you know
working helping with the egress plan so
he was quite happy with it on a normal
day
uh we'd instructed the security that
they were they were on the clock and
paid until everything was clear they
wouldn't be our shifts finished we've
got a really good team that we've been
working with who have been back this
weekend and are more than happy to
support so it will be a manned egress
plan we were holding people back on our
premises with defenses and allowing
people out to taxes into buses uh making
sure people weren't in the road or on
the roundabout i've i've looked out this
window and onto the roundabout for the
last 10 years and we know
how it is quite a quick and a fast round
that's our main concern people in the
road directly outside the building so we
are very conscious you know about
keeping control of that i understand the
wider spread of people not being able to
leave this is
a fresh problem
right okay thank you um does anybody
else have a a question for the applicant
please
uh sophie sorry councillor taylor yeah
hello i'm mr oliver um i can see that
you're very committed to providing a
really uh safe and effective and
enjoyable event for your customers um
just my question really and and you know
you obviously acknowledge you know that
the location of it is not not probably
the easiest to find it at the best of
times is it and so my concern is how
and you've obviously got some experience
communicating the need to use your laid
on coaches and taxes to enable the
customers depart safely you know so they
know that that is the expectation and
not to try and leave in any other way
because you know my fear is that people
in
afghanistan place if you don't know the
area isn't it really
um you know and
obviously you know if people can't get
away or they came to some harm or you
know that that wouldn't be a good
reputation for your business or us as a
borough really would it so you know
about
ensuring that people know that that is
the agreed plan that they um leave the
event safely
at the moment uh again the
promoters is it's basically two uh
promotion events that are being put
together both of these being close
friends of ours
i would say of the 500 attending
probably
200 plus are close friends of me and my
partner anyway because we we know a big
amount of those people we've already
spoke to the two event organizers and
they are more than on board they're
committed to keeping it at this space
because this is something we've been
talking about since the creation of our
venue they've come in and we've had
private birthdays in in the past and
they're very committed to using this
space and and they want to do something
here this was kind of the one date that
we picked out so six months ahead the
only date they could do because they do
festivals all summer and they were
gutted when they found out so they
they've said they're committed they're
happy to release everything on all the
ticket forums all of their
correspondence everyone who buys a
ticket it obviously submits their email
everyone with a ticket or without a
ticket have the email sent out for this
plan to let them know that with risk
cancellation there is a marathon on and
we will be laying on a bus service
okay and is it an entirely ticketed
event so people have to buy the tickets
sorry sorry i think i missed your last
point because you froze go on
no i said it so it is a ticketed event
um at the moment we expect to sell out
long before the event i think they last
time they checked again announced
without because they've got they've got
potential places they don't want to use
that they they've got on reservation and
they've sold 250 tickets as of last week
so they're nearly halfway there they
reckon this will be sold out long before
the show
but they everyone who buys a ticket will
be through skiddle and through the the
registered
uh outlets which will all register by
email so everyone when the tickets get
sent out before the event we can send
them correspondence we can
tell them tomorrow that you you know you
need to take a covered test you know all
those things we can send out to the
customers and anyone buying it can have
a warning so they said they would
absolutely release a plan uh sending the
email the road closure document you know
for the marathon let everyone know that
we want to keep the event alive and
we're laying on a bus service for him
and that this is the expected way to get
you back to a predetermined point
they're fully on board they want to keep
it here i said can we have asked already
can we reschedule and they're like we do
not have any time where we're going to
get all these people back together
before
end of september
so they are committed to trying to
trying to keep this alive and do what
they can they said whatever we need
whatever support they will put whatever
messages out you know from both ticket
outlets
but they are they are as committed as i
am to try and keep it going
but safety is a main concern
like we we pay because we know we're out
in the sticks we pay for a
from like um a medics company to come in
and be here for any events you know for
people who might be a little too tired
you know through the night and you know
we make sure we've got a you know a
proper
insured service safety is number one you
know we i've started as an engineer for
me and my mum and directors on on the
board so
safety's number one priority we're just
trying to do everything we can to keep
this was like the biggest one in our
calendar to date and we're just trying
to keep it alive essentially i think any
other night i probably would have just
said we can't do it i'm sorry it just
happens to be you know the one that
we've really worked hard on for quite
some time
yeah i know i appreciate everything that
you're saying you know and it obviously
is it's a really important event isn't
it it's quite prestigious bad sounds but
yeah um yeah but obviously we're on the
same page we all want our customers to
be safe is there any chance that um
people could arrive you know without
tickets or try and seek admission you
know without having prior booking um
the
if the tickets are sold out there would
be no more admission anyway uh that's
that's a given um
as as far as to tell you that somebody
couldn't walk past and see that this
event on we've got no control of that
uh but the tickets will be announced
when they sell out they will be
announced online that it's completely
sold out you know that's standard
practice
um people turning up
who walk past would just be denied entry
but at the same time if people seen
there was an event and thought they
might chance it i would imagine they
would get hit by
you know similar things i think you
usually have a last entry between one
and one thirty on these sort of things
uh the latest and then gates closed like
the site gets locked down the security
at the perimeter so no one else would be
admitted
uh i don't know
again what responsibility we have of of
people walking past but that's
it's not they they would not be admitted
once we hit capacity which we accept
that we expect to reach you know before
the start of the event
i know i know one other one other events
if we don't hit capacity say we've got a
for you know there's a shortfall you do
accept door admission but on this one we
would expect not to
i think we've already spoke as well
there is a united home game on the
second yes and we we run that in the day
and we will be closing early at the five
o'clock kickoff time and not reopening
for after the after the game to avoid
any additional admission or people
wanting to join from the football will
close for a number of hours for the
football to finish people to leave the
area and then we will reopen for the
event later so we've addressed that
issue with the police as well that we
won't kind of have the crossover from
one crowd to the other trying to come
into the event and create more
difficulties we have already addressed
that and agreed to close that
off separation between those
the separation yeah yeah
okay thank you very much thanks for
answering those questions
thank you does anybody else have a
any questions for the applicant
can i should i just ask to recap are you
saying you then you're happy to um work
up the agreement with the bus company
yeah i'm i'm happy to
say withdraw
and
and re-submit it with all of our final
egress plan put together
uh but again as i clarified the
questions i'd have to submit it as the
pair
so
[Music]
and get started
with the whole thing with the egress
package with confirmed bus companies and
we've got the prices everything is good
i'll rewrite it out as a proper plan and
then if we still hit a roadblock at the
end
if we're all happy that i will remove
day two and still keep day one because i
don't want to ruin the people who have
set day one up for this day too oh yeah
i'll i'll happily do that withdraw and
resubmit
with the egress plan fully complete i'll
get letters from the security from the
taxi company let us intent from the bus
companies to make sure that's all in
there that everyone's aware
and from the promoters that they were
happy to put it on and kind of get their
response that will go on the ticket
sites i can get all that in writing and
put into the package i think that covers
everything
that we talked about today
okay well thanks for that um you just
froze in the middle the middle of what
you were saying but uh i think we got
the gist of it we got the most of it
actually so i'll just bring in our
environmental health officer
um
she wants to
make a contribution
um no i mean
as i say um
in in the current form um the tent that
has been applied for you know we would
still have have the objection um
just on account of sort of the public
transport routes out and also the
concerns around public safety of people
egressing the venue um if it was
modified or
it you know and and we got written
confirmation
um of the measures that um samuel was
offering to put in place then we would
we would definitely have a look at it
again and work with him which is what
i've offered um you know right from the
start so um
as i say in its current form it still
stands that you know old object
to it
okay thank you does anybody
sorry can i quickly ask as well when we
discussed before
about potential
multiple drop-off points so it's not all
the same if i'm putting this back
together are you happy to for me to
liaise with you to find out what what
works better nicola if i if i'm putting
this together are you happy for me to to
ask the questions if they arrive while
i'm yeah yeah definitely yeah i think
you just need to get people out of the
area away from the road closures really
um into manchester uh it would be a
point because i think they'll be able to
get out the other way yeah
my concern then was if i was to say take
four buses to piccadilly station would
that create you another issue or would
you be happy well we could we could
involve tfgm in the conversation and you
know they would advise whether that
would be my concern i put all the effort
into that and then dumping everyone in
one place is another issue so yeah i'm
sure i mean it happens quite a lot with
with other festivals where they use
shuttle buses and they take them to
certain points
um if you've obviously got information
on your ticketing about where people are
coming from that might help you to make
that decision if you can look at post
code data and see where people are going
back to
um that would be probably useful for you
to it to address pick up points but i
don't i don't see i don't see it being
an issue as long as you can get people
away out of traffic yeah yeah okay yeah
i'll work it on that basis
okay thank you yeah can i just ask one
more question to mr oliver can i just
inquire i think you
suggested that if it weren't possible to
um work up a manageable solution for the
event on the second would you still go
ahead and just put in a standalone um
application for the first you couldn't
you could probably with that is there
anything
i really we definitely 100 we want to
proceed with the first and i know
there's no problem yeah question i asked
before uh just to confirm
was
if i was to submit one for the first and
one for the second there's not a 24 hour
gap in between so i can't submit two
tens to cover them both i'd have to
resubmit one tens covering both events
and if you're not happy with with my
egress plan for the second i'd have to
modify it again and just remove that
event to keep the first right
if i submit two separate ones that i
asked the question because i've read a
lot
i wouldn't have that 24 24-hour gap and
it'd be a technicality
yeah i understand okay thank you
yeah i think the first one's
non-controversial um there seems to be a
measure of agreement but uh we just need
to uh
have a recess just to discuss it
with the uh the legal representative
does anybody
else have any final questions for
either of the parties
we've got one uh
john
yeah
uh not so much questions suggestion
while we've been talking i've had a look
at a map
and you've got two routes
for foot people
out of your site
across the canal
one to media city and one to the lowry
center
and i don't know whether you've
considered those as potential
pickup points and potential dispersal
points but if you haven't i'd recommend
you look at that because i think that
has the advantage
providing the weather
of course
out away from the road closures and into
a network of roads
going everywhere
yeah well i think media city would
definitely we we moved to media city
when when we opened the restaurant uh
just for ease and we would definitely
there's a short link around
and over to the center immediately
around coronation street and uh and over
the bridge yeah so the the local bridge
that is here is a walking bridge only
and you would have to go
milanian bridge
they're both footbridges i appreciate
that but you can have your vehicle pick
up points
well away from
the road closures just important
the issue we've had with that dealing
with uh john at the
licensing and the police is that we
don't want people who are tired or
inebriated walking
in the streets of trafford park in the
morning because if you've got big wagons
you're not expecting people to be in the
road and if we start asking people to
egress away from sight we've got no
control over whether they're walking on
the pavements or dancing around we want
to try and get them into transport we
fence off the front of our gates and
onto next doors car park with we've got
their permission and we try and egress
people into taxis and not allow them out
onto the street so we'd be filling the
buses
on site and having them leave rather
than letting people go out of our site
the security state i think that's the
main concern if they could walk down the
road they could walk back to manchester
uh we don't want them to be out in the
streets where wagons and trucks and
metros you know could could not know
what i expect and to be there appreciate
that so
yeah you've clearly thought about it
much more than i have
i believe we would definitely consider
one of the buses egressing around this
is the bridge over at cargill that goes
into media city and possibly drop the
people in where there's the metro
stations and and the tram links that way
but i've not studied the plan for a
couple of days since i sent it over to
to the bus company so
okay the main thing was not allowing
people to be freely walking the streets
you know not under supervision in
industrial area
okay i don't know
okay thank you uh both the center and
the applicant have an opportunity to sum
up for two minutes if they wish to
um nicola do you wish to
say anything i don't have anything else
to add
no i've never do i don't i think i think
i know exactly what i need to do and
i'll i'll go away and very much i didn't
get the paperwork done
um in terms of objection or withdrawal
is can i withdraw or are we past the
point of withdrawal and now by going to
committee yeah again i'm not sure how
this works no i don't think so i mean uh
joanne would you like to
respond
i've never had this situation
it's a bit unconventional
i would say he could
could we draw it at any time
it's the timing really as long as you've
got the timing
yeah i i think i'd actually
there's no objection then obviously you
wouldn't have to convene another i've
got to get it in kind of before 10 days
before to not be late
yeah so we're just saying that
yeah you need to get in by the 19
by the 19.
um my colleague katie who's observing is
just mentioned that um she was going to
mention to you that you need to get it
in by then though as it would be a late
10.
right okay well i will aim to have it in
by the 16th realistically uh resubmitted
and then at least the process is not
late and i'll be able to take the the
extra day out once it's in process
the obligation upon the committee is to
hold a hearing after an injection has
been raised
um whilst you've been talking i have
been looking to see it needs rather
unusual circumstances whether there
would be any
difficulty in adjourning the hearing to
avoid the need to submit a new tent
because there is this cut off this
10-day working period
now it seems to me that there is no
reason why the hearing cannot be
adjourned or the committee
meeting cannot be adjourned
but
there may be practical and logistical
problems about that because if it were
to be adjourned then it would have to be
the same
three uh
subcommittee members that came back on
the matter
um but you are clearly seized of it i
think there will be two
practical issues that you might want to
explore before considering that uh
course of action one would be the
logistics of it but secondly how long mr
oliver thinks that it would take
for him to conclude
what he needs to do to
um attempt to reach uh agreement with mr
duckworth
i don't know whether that's helpful
church or as um well yeah i think he
thinks about another week i mean the
problem we've got is
we've got meetings every night probably
um but there again if if it's to the
satisfaction of the environmental health
officer
then
you know we could cancel we could we
could adjourn it but then we wouldn't
need we would have the need for the
second hearing
um
because obviously
purdue starts on the 28th of
march and then you know every night
we've got because everybody's trying to
cram meetings in before then i
appreciate licensing public protection
can go on beyond you know
[Music]
um it's just
you know the plumber for meetings in the
time scale but i mean
we could discuss that in the closed
session that's
okay
but if if you think you're able to do
that and it stops me having to
withdraw and reapply i'm happy to just
improve the tens get all the written
confirmation we've discussed from
forces taxis promoters security and and
have that i'm happy to go down that
route if you think it works for you but
if that creates a lot more problems i'll
i'll essentially be resubmitting the
same documents either way it's just
whether the paperwork becomes more
difficult and the the time out is an
issue
well effectively there's agreement
between yourself and the environmental
health officer with no need to
you know we could we could adjourn it
but we don't need to have the second
hearing basically but it it makes it
easier i suspect it would and
i think that's probably what we'd do
okay so
if there's enough being said in this
session we will adjourn for a few
minutes to go into the closed session
and then